bhindi and Chandler hanging on the beach
kis s ing there is someone special in my
life right now the 17 year old and her
wakeboard pro boyfriend Chandler Powell
vacationed in Hawaii recently and et has
the pics of their affectionate beachside
PDA the couple embraced under the Sun
and shared a sweet kiss in this snap
looking super in love then the pair
flaunted their beach bods taking a dip
in the ocean bindi rocked high-waisted
Jean cut-offs and Chandler in a striped
pair of board shorts their best
accessory though definitely those big
smiles bindi and Chandler weren't alone
in Paradise and I witnessed lzt they
were joined on Oahu's North Shore by
bindis mom teri brother Robert and a few
other relatives the i-witness added that
bindi and Chandler were quote constantly
together and enjoyed day trips with the
group hiking eating visiting a pineapple
plantation and apparently even some
impromptu karaoke bindi shared this
hilarious video of her love and her baby
bro
getting there Adele on